very pleased to say we're joined now by
the chief executive of the uk health
security agency dr jenny harris dr
harris it's been a busy couple of days
for you i'm sure so i'm very glad that
you've been able to make the time uh to
speak to us and of course so much uh to
discuss at following the ukhsa's report
from yesterday and i do want to take you
back to a comment that you made about
the omicron variant when you when you
said that it was the most serious threat
that the uk had faced during the
pandemic on the basis of what the uk hsa
reported yesterday
can you now moderate that that
that judgment on omicron
so i think we can start to moderate that
comment but we don't yet have all the
information that we need
when i made that comment it was because
we had very high degrees of uncertainty
we had a new variant which was showing
uh clear uh signs in its structure and
our its expected behavior that it would
evade some of our immune defenses and
that's exactly what we found we've seen
in um in both the laboratory studies on
antibody
teachers on the antibody studies and in
fact in some of our vaccine
effectiveness studies for symptomatic
infection that there is a reduced effect
in comparison to the effects of our
vaccines against delta
what that report yesterday showed
however
is that where we're starting to look now
at some of the signals against how
effective our vaccines are
and potentially previous infections are
against omicron compared with delta we
can see that less people
are coming into a hospital
and it appears that there is a reduced
signal of
risk of hospitalization so that's a good
sign but
as you would have heard just then dr
hopkins saying uh chief medical advisor
that um these are very early days it's
very small numbers and most of the cases
of omicron in this country so far to
date have been in younger people we're
only just now starting to see them tip
into the uh over 60s and just this week
into the over 70s group and that's where
we start being very worried yeah and of
course heading into christmas when so
many people will be associating with the
generations of their family that we may
well have a data set on that in the not
too distant future but but in addition
to that i mean i don't want to get all
donald rumsfeld here and start talking
about unknown unknowns but what do we
not yet know about omicron before we can
say actually do you know what this was a
threat
during the pandemic is not the most
serious one
so the point i've made just now about
the age group we really need to
understand that's really critical
because we know the majority of uh
individuals who've sadly had to come
into hospitals or who died have been in
those older age groups we need to
understand how that impacts with
underlying conditions as you get older
you tend to have
more con
other illnesses alongside to contend
with but i think some of the other
features we really need to understand as
well because the problem with omicron is
we've got lots and lots of cases so even
if
the severity is potentially reduced we
still need to deal with these 119 000
that was a record number of cases that
were recorded yesterday so the sorts of
things we need to see is if somebody
does come into hospital do they for
example stay the same length of time as
somebody who had delta do they need the
same levels of oxygen
do they need to go to intensive care as
frequently and all of those will signal
what the pressures are likely to be on
our health services
yeah of course in terms of the doubling
rate around about two between two and
three days at the moment a couple of
weeks ago when
when we first started really getting
concerned about omicron there was a
suggestion that within a fortnight we
could see you know new cases on a daily
basis up to two hundred thousand it's
clearly not got to to that state yet in
terms at least of those those that have
been tested are slowing perhaps of the
growth in the growth rate why do we
think that might be is it because of the
behavioral changes that many many people
have made
given statements from yourself and the
prime minister or is it just perhaps
different rates of spread between
different groups so i think there's a
number of different points there number
one i'm not sure i would agree that the
growth rate that we have strong evidence
it has come down it's around two two
days for uh doubling time
for most regions across the country and
it is very high in london still
so i think we shouldn't accept that as
you've noticed uh noted that people do
have different behaviors around their
testing over festive periods and so for
the next few days we think the data will
likely not give a particularly true
picture it's likely to come back in on
track as we go past the festive season
um so i think that those are the the key
key points in relation to
of course we are expecting perhaps uh to
hear something in terms of additional
restrictions perhaps as early as next
week from the government uh one item
from from the sage minutes which have
just been released which which led to my
attention is this and i'm giving this to
you site on scene so apologies dr harris
the minute says this data will be
unreliable over the festive period as
testing and hospital admission patterns
change this will make it difficult to
interpret any apparent trends over the
next few days do you believe that the
prime minister the chief medical advisor
chief scientific officer
will have the evidence to be able to
make a decision early next week on
further restrictions
there's probably three pieces of of
evidence and they are being looked at on
a daily basis and we will obviously be
continuing to provide that uh
information over christmas so i think
that that is a certainty we we keep
looking at the data all of the time um
number one is it's actually the ons
survey the community infection survey
which is run routinely which
systematically samples people across the
country and we thank all of them for
their help
that gives us the background infection
numbers now not all of those people who
have infections in the community
sometimes because they don't know
they're asymptomatic they won't always
come forward so there is always a
difference and it goes back to your 200
000 number if we actually look at what
ons uh is saying at the moment there's
somewhere around uh in the previous week
uh they estimate 1.2 to 1.5 million
people had coronavirus doing during that
week now those are not the numbers that
come through through our testing so we
always know that there is a difference
there but i think the third point is
actually looking at what we're really
concerned about we're concerned about
people's health we're concerned about
transmission but most of all we're
concerned to make sure that our health
services can keep functioning and of
course the health service data continues
to come back in on a daily basis and
again that is looked at regularly so i
think the short answer is yes we have
the data good um just in terms though um
uh doctor something you mentioned a
moment ago something you alluded to a a
couple of moments ago that doesn't seem
to be within uh the hospital within our
hospitals at the moment the pressures on
intensive care and on on ventilators
that you might have expected is that
just a concomitant of that which we were
discussing before that you know the
majority of people going in are slightly
younger at the moment so that's one of
the uncertainties you're absolutely
right it's relatively early days there's
always a lag between the rising
community cases and of course this has
happened so quickly that we're still
literally only four weeks since we came
across this new variant and but we will
we do anticipate more cases will come in
as cases appear
in the older age groups but we are
seeing signals across other countries
and we monitor that routinely that
suggests that perhaps the length of stay
in hospital is a little bit less people
are not needing oxygen quite so much and
perhaps not going through to
intensive care the only caveat i would
put on that is of course we had
relatively high
case rates before we found omicron
and our hospitals are trying to deal
valiantly as they always do with routine
winter pressures so i think uh there is
what pressure is the nhs under and then
what contribution is omicron making and
it's both of those together that we need
to take into account
um dodge harris of course you're a lot
closer to those making the the political
decisions and all this i barely get a
card from an mp these days um so you may
well disagree with what i'm about to
suggest but it certainly feels like from
the government's perspective
hospitalizations
remains the key data point in terms of
further restrictions but given what we
are seeing particularly in the health
service in london significant numbers of
staff themselves are are off with
omicron it feels like you know staffing
might well become a tipping point for
further restrictions
so staffing for the health service for
the care service i'd like to just you
know of course yes that's a balance as
well for all our carers out there and
actually for many of our other critical
infrastructure services you will want to
ensure you have some food on your table
for your christmas meal tomorrow and
subsequently um and of course what we
have done is looked at the evidence
around the isolation period and what is
safe and we now have uh lateral flow
test new rapid antigen tests available
uh this year that we didn't have last
year and so we've been able to safely
reduce the isolation period down as long
as people are taking and have two
negative uh lateral flow devices 24
hours apart so that actually starts to
address some of the workforce issues and
for health and care workforce who are
clearly dealing with the most vulnerable
they actually take additional tests to
make sure that is safe for them to
return to work at that point so um it is
it is an important point for all our
critical services all our frontline
services
but we have ways
for that you know through that example
of managing that and obviously contacts
as well we now have lateral flow tests
to ensure that people
are very unlikely to return to work even
if they're a contact and uh and uh you
know making sure that they're not
infectious when they go back
indeed and and good point well taken
about those working in the care sector
dr harris um i wonder if we might
conclude our talk and thank you for
spending as much time as you have with
us we've got obviously had a lot to get
through at talking about the prospect of
an additional booster already there
seems to be a view emerging that a
fourth shot
rather earlier than many people might
have expected it might be necessary and
of course we know that there will be
what ongoing about an omicron specific
vaccine at the moment but in your view
is it just a question of when
we get a fourth job rather than if
so obviously jcvi joint committee on
vaccination immunization we'll be
looking at this data continuously and in
fact they do that routinely for any
vaccinations it's quite normal for our
response to a vaccine to to wane and
then we have a booster we see it with
childhood boosters for example
obviously this is a new variant and it
will take time for us to understand that
pattern but i think the critical point
here is that even where we have seen uh
some apparent waning against um a
symptomatic infection
we have not seen that subsequent waning
in the same time frame against serious
uh infections serious disease and
hospitalizations and deaths so i think
this is far too early at the moment to
call whether we need uh to have yet
another booster um obviously as i say
jcbr we'll keep a look on that and we
will look at the vaccine effectiveness
and our hospital data on a daily basis
as we go forward and publish in due
course
i don't always i do hope you could not
get any presence to wrap because i'm
going to hold on to you for another
couple of minutes we've just had a
little bit of interesting data coming
from up from the ons and we were talking
about this just a second ago and they
estimate 1.7 million people in the uk
had covered 19 in the week up to
december the 19th the highest number
since compatible figures back began back
in autumn 2020. i i suppose is that
within the bulk of the park of what you
would have expected given the
transmissibility of omicron
so i think what we're seeing is very
very high growth rates and and you're
absolutely right i think uh the data
translates through something like 1 in
35
people across england have covered and
in london it's something like a
staggering one in 15. this is very
uh you know we haven't seen rates like
this before but it is predominantly
still an infection of younger people so
the 20 to 29 year group particularly
we've still got some delta cases in very
young children and we have
delta cases in those people mostly who
are currently in hospital so this is a
very very mixed picture
and as we've just been discussing some
of the critical things
in in managing this is to be absolutely
sure
what the severity risk is and our data
at the moment is still quite early i
mean i think it gives me an opportunity
just to reinforce on those figures
exactly that when people are enjoying
their christmases and we really want
them to that we don't let omicron enjoy
it as well that they should be
being careful about what they're doing
obviously
doing face hands space ventilate the
rooms that they're in and particularly
if you're going to visit somebody who is
vulnerable in any way or has
immunosuppression
to do a lateral flow test before you go
so that you know you can see them safely
and they can feel comfortable